[Música]
me gusta comprar flores en las ramblas
aunque en verano dejó de ir porque con
el calor las flores se mueren enseguida
y por las vacaciones
una mañana del pasado otoño recupere mi
costumbre y me dirigí a mi parada
habitual al verme mi florista de
cabecera que es un señor mayor que
siempre está muy serio me sonrió
y me dijo que me había echado en falta
los hablar unos segundos de sus
vacaciones de las mías me di cuenta de
que lo que le preocupaba no era que le
estuviera comprando las flores a otro
lo que le preocupaba es que yo ya no
estuviera que yo hubiera sido una de las
17 personas que murieron los atentados
de las ramblas
17 de agosto de 2017
porque él sabe que yo vivo en el barrio
y él por aquellas fechas tenía la parada
cerrada por vacaciones
cuando me fui puso su mano sobre mi
brazo y me dijo me alegro de que estés
bien que en realidad significaba me
alegro de que esté viva
al cabo de unos meses la parada cerro
por jubilación y nada ha rellenado su
hueco
vive en el barrio gótico de barcelona es
así es una montaña rusa a veces de
maravillas porque no puedes dejar de
amar tu barrio
te gustan las calles te gusta ir a
comprar a la boquería las paradas que
quedan aunque sea contra viento y marea
te encanta tener tanta diversidad con
tan solo salir de casa aunque cada vez
sea más difícil de encontrar
a veces
a veces te entra a penas
porque a paso lento e inexorable van
desapareciendo una a una aquellas cosas
que lo hacen tu barrio
las personas
las tiendas cierran por jubilación por
la subida del alquiler por agotamiento y
te encuentras paseando entre ojos que te
miran pero no te ven
quieres probar de una muerte con from
the day te gritan desde las tiendas al
pasar
pasó tres veces en el mismo día y me
repite lo mismo una y otra vez es que no
se dan cuenta de que vivo en este barrio
que esta es mi calle
no
una vez me paré delante de una de ellas
y pedí por favor que dejaran de
ofrecerme sus productos con tanta
violencia resulta alienante pasar una y
otra vez y oír la misma exigencia en
bucle
la respuesta literalmente fue
no voy a hacer un esfuerzo por
recordarte
y s
ese es el problema
y tendrá la rabia
no sabes qué hacer con ella y te vías a
tomar algo para distraerte un poco de
este mal humor que se te está acumulando
pero los locales están llenos de gente
que seguramente solo los va a visitar
una vez así que te cuesta encontrar tus
sitios
y poco a poco te vas
poniendo de más mal humor te resulta
cansino cruzar tu propia calle y hasta
lo evitas
y
no paras de chocar contra gente que
camina hacia atrás imbuida por el noble
arte del modelaje o la fotografía
de sentirte invisible
y otras veces tienes que dar un rodeo
muy grande para llegar a tu casa porque
hay un grupo enorme bloqueando una calle
muy estrecha para probar los auténticos
churros ver el auténtico estilo gótico
del siglo 20 y yo que sé
y cada vez estás poniendo de mal humor
y qué haces
qué haces en el día a día para no darlo
todo por perdido para no largar t
una opción que yo propongo es fijarte en
los que resisten porque llevan décadas
adaptándose a las modas de piel de la
ciudad
un día
en el que la vida en el barrio gótico se
me hacía especialmente asfixiante me fui
a ver a mi zapatero vive en el taller a
tres manzanas de mi casa
/
le di los buenos días como las vacas
miran al tren
y le pedí que me encanta las tapas de
los zapatos
al verme mi zapatero pero dijo lo que
estaba haciendo me sonrió y me dijo
hace un buen día verdad
y se quedó ahí sonriendo y mirándome él
me veía
me veía enfadada triste apresurada
adoptando la prisa de los que corren
para comprar más para vender más para
atraer más
y yo no me había dado cuenta de que todo
eso era ajeno
y allí
parada en aquel minúsculo local me di
cuenta de la fortuna que era porque si
ese día era especialmente radiante
y ya había tenido la suerte de que
alguien me mirara a los ojos y me
hiciera ver con una sonrisa y la prisa
se esfumó y dejé de sentirme invisible
dejé de sentirme sin importancia
después de 50 años de ver a la gente
entrar en su taller de ver el mundo
cambiar del derecho y del revés mi
zapatero sí que tiene la clave de cómo
sobrevivir a un barrio muy turístico él
y el joven que me afilar los cuchillos y
la mujer que deben de la loza
y la que me envuelve las libretas nuevas
en papel de estraza
y otros más
aunque ya no muchos
para sobrevivir en el día a día en un
barrio muy turístico te fijas en los que
resisten porque ellos tienen mucho que
enseñarte te concentras en ellos y no en
lo que está de paso
te enseñan una cierta actitud un cierto
ritmo una cierta amabilidad que es casi
revolucionaria en este ambiente
y vuelves a los mismos sitios con tu
tiempo sabiendo que con la decisión de
dónde gastar tu dinero y con qué actitud
sales a la calle reclamas tu espacio
y si es más rápido y más fácil hacer un
clic en internet o si hay un lugar nos
ha aireado donde gastar tu dinero y tu
tiempo pero esas acciones también
definen el espacio en el que vives
aunque no en la manera en la que tú
quieres
vamos a ponerlo en cifras barcelona
recibe 12 millones de turistas al año
estos 12 millones son en realidad los
que se alojan en hoteles y
alojamientos similares porque en
realidad bueno y apartamentos turísticos
con licencia en realidad no ha
encontrado la cifra global de personas
que visitan la ciudad barcelona
tiene seis millones y medio de
habitantes de los cuales 15.000 vivimos
en el barrio gótico
esta cifra
se está manteniendo estable ahora aunque
los últimos años estábamos perdiendo mil
vecinos por año
todas estas cifras significan muchas
cosas pero a mí lo que me dejan son
personas que me conocían
y comercios donde me conocían que
cierran
otros para los que soy invisible y
riadas de gente que solo está de paso
así que este es mi consejo para
sobrevivir un barrio muy turístico te
vuelves hacia los que resisten te fijas
en ellos porque están ahí
si te fijas puedes identificarlos
cuidarlos y aprender de ellos es lo que
te da un sentido de pertenencia
y este es mi consejo para todos los que
se sientan invisibles y este es mi
homenaje para todos aquellos que con su
actitud no se arraigan
[Aplausos]
[Música]